behind the bench the San Jose Sharks 22
wins last year they're rebuilding he's
a patient coach once again the Panthers without
Alexander barov officially in illness Mika kept it
alive start pushing the puck by Nika early on
chance for stenin and it would go on the backhand
St was alone in front here's Mika again stenin up
high takes the shot wide kulakov down the boards
Samus kevich kicked it three Panther's able to
change lines with the far change in the first
period without leaving the Zone Steven Lawrence
the former shark in behind W around attempt stop
then it goes wide Lockwood had a chance first
opportunity as the Florida Panthers look at
that strong on the puck you got the secondary
pressure Lawrence comes around tries to R the
line with benedi PCH binus nice feet ahead
stenin lomber in front stenin stopped B kak
he'll take that ice and he'll try and jam
it in he'll either lift it over top of the
goenda good kick save neither is Justin
sord if neither any of the young players
sit around and not play games where they
can go to AHL Charlotte and get games in
samoskevich called up with barov ill tonight
will Lockwood on that line spoke to him this
morning he was chopping at the bit thrilled to
get in so underway in the second larin's line
Begins the period and a steel Lo T got
the stick check in there finds kachuck
down low kachuck tries to stuff it in on
Blackwood he makes the save and a whistle
flips it ahead Lawrence reaches out pulls
it in tussles with emberson gets through
centering feet save by Lockwood Florence
with the work for haggy with the [Music]
opportunity now kof out there the defenseman sent
into the panther Zone eckan centers tipped at the
net by zland never got the stolar though bordalo
pass blocked by Mika eckan centers and they score
stolar was looking the other side and Zin hammers
it in it's one- nothing San Jose on the power play
well was a Nifty play by the San Jose Sharks
right here at the end of this power play see
mikay tries to force the play now watch here right
at the top of your screen this area right here and
you see stolar he's looking this way and then he's
going to go back to the other way and here's what
happens and before the Panthers could
get any coverage at all that reverse
pass good effort by Veri to hold this in the
zone bsing slides down the board PUK in behind
and they score it's car number Hy from kachuck
and the Panthers answer back tied at one
[Applause] [Music] watch the puck go behind
the net and con check all he does is just let
it go because the defense here comes forsing
the pinch in and as soon as he does that San
Jose is all caught on that side and look at
the time nobody's covering Veri puts it off the
goal tender to the defenseman Burrows Sharks win
another face off and get it out of the zone and
this is bordalo save by stolar side of the net
Puck is loose comes out in front and stolen
away by samoskevich Macky on the move against
kesia Macky to the net taken down no call emman
Larson again P Chu weits cross ice Eckman Larson
the [__] black with the save score reinard is
there and the Panthers have the lead [Applause]
oh he's so sneaky that sneaky Sam Reinhardt
even though he lost his balance he was spun
around right at the top of that crease area the
shot came from emman Larson there's ryanard at
the bottom of your screen down he goes and
on the ice he's able to spin around and look
at how gets that stick on the puck and enough
to get it over the goal line that's his office
right there let your man slip away and give an
odd man rush or a down low play to the Sharks
and they've been excellent at that this year
the Panthers so far they're you know working
in the four new defensemen all the scoring came
in the second period in a span of less than seven
minutes Hoffman off the cross bar oh Mike Hoffman
Let it Fly and see he winds that up and shoots it
high and it goes over the blocker Rodriguez with
speed finds Reinhardt back for Rodriguez behind
manette skates away from Benning turns and shoots
High kulakov able to play it duclair turns shot to
[Applause] flex Burrows from the board shoots
deflected by hurdle over the net Benning on the
other side barabanov in front duclair trying
to pull down stolar he's just too big and too
tough and he wouldn't give Anthony duclair any
room Panthers trying to get the insurance goal
here Atman Larson for haggy Moves In Front oh
kachuck deflection is stopped kachuck looking
for his first of the Season he's been buzzing
around that net all night here he is again
setting up rein Hart denight Reinhardt on the
follow it's blocked away here's number two good
Chuck to Reinhardt oh what a save by Blackwood
there Reinhardt gives it back Alber hegy in the
slot shoots oh that's off the crossbar and then
the third one here floats in off the shoulder of
Blackwood Veri got it through they say it stayed
out Veri again kachuck one more time sweeps it
on goal Blackwood the [Applause] save [Applause]
Hoffman one timer loose in front bouncing around
stolar is trying to find it here they set up
Hoffman for the one timer star's come across
that shot was block but then the scramble
the Panthers could not find it there's the
overhead look right there the action right out
in front San Jose is utilizing their timeout
and good work there by forsling he tied up his
men and San Jose looking for one more chance
hurdle stolen away by forsling Ean Larson
trying to clear and they do kachuck stenland
Bingo Kevin stenland puts it away 3 to one
Panthers you go back to when the Panthers
were shorthanded it was a six on four for San
Jose making sure they're on the right side of
the puck there is swatted out kachuck stenin
and he puts it in the open net with 1.5 seconds
remaining the Panthers put that on display
going back to killing that penalty points
on the board Panthers find a way to get
the two the rats come out Sam Reinhardt